موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
استشهاد الشاب سامح اقطش متاثرا بجروح نصب
بها برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في قريه
زعتره جنوبيه نابلس
وكان الهلال الاحمر قد اعلن اصابه النحو
100 فلسطيني نتيجه اعتداءات المستوطنين
بحمايه جنود الاحتلال على منازل وسياراتي
ومحل الفلسطينيين في بلده حواره في نابلس
احتجاجا على مقتل مستوطنين في حادث اطلاق
نار في البلده
وقد خرجت تماسيرات في عدد من المدن
والبلدات في الضفه الغربيه ضد الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه وطلب المتظاهرون بالحمايه من
تلك الاعتداءات في جميع المدن والبلدات
الفلسطينيه
في غضون ذلك قال الناطق باسم قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بياننا الجيش دفع
بكتيبتين عسكريتين جديدتين الى الضفه
الغربيه
في الاثناء قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو من البناء الاستيطانيه
وتشريع البؤر الاستيطانيه في الضفه
الغربيه
سايتواصلان دون اي تغيير جاء كلامه
نتنياهو في اول رد فعل حكومي على نتائج
اجتماع العقبه في الاردن الذي اقر
التفهمات من بينها التزام الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي بخفض التصعيد ومنع
العنف وتعليق مؤقت للاجراءات الاحاديه
والانشطه الاستيطانيه الجديده اضافه الى
الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي القائم في
الاماكن المقدسه
وقلا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين الاجتماع
العقبه خطوه ايجابيه للاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ومن الاهميه متابعه الطرفين
خطوات تهدئه التوترات واستعاده الهدوء
وقد نددت فصائل فلسطينيه بمشاركه مسؤولينا
فلسطينيين في اجتماع العقبه في الاردن
وحضرت من توفير غطاء لجرائم الاحتلال
وقالت الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان المشاركه
الفلسطينيه في اجتماع العقبه جريمه وطنيه
لا يمكن السكوت عنها وحذرت من تبعاتها
اقاموا الصلاه قالت قيده الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قوتها صدت واحدا وسبعين
هجوما روسيا واضافت انها احبطت العديد من
المحاولات الروسيه للتقدم نحو مواقع
قواتها في مخمط من جهته قلائد القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيين الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات من الشركاء الغربيين غير كافيه
واقل المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه
ان اوكرانيا ستكون مستعده للقيام بهجوم
مضاد في الربيع
في غضون ذلك قال الرئيس الروسي ان روسيا
في مواجهه فعليه مع النيتو واضاف ان على
بلاده ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار القدرات
النوويه لدول الحلف كبريطانيا وفرنسا
ارتفع عدد قتل حادثي ارتطام قارب خشبي
بالصخور قباله السواحل الايطاليه الى نحو
60 شخصا من طالبيه اللجوء بينهم اطفال
يذكر ان الحكومه الايطاليه اليمنيه تبنت
قوانين جديده صارمه تقيد عمليات الانقاذ
في البحر وتعرقل وصولا جينا لموانئها
نهايه الموضه انا ما كنتم وبت اوقاتكم بكل
خير